se hace una función definida para todos
los números reales además sea que prima
la derivada de gente definida como g
prima de x igual a x cuadrada entre x
menos 2 elevado a la tercera potencia
para que intervalo es la función g es
creciente la función g es creciente ojo
porque seguramente lo primero que vas a
pensar es si no tenemos la función g
como vamos a averiguar dónde está
creciendo bueno la respuesta a esa
pregunta sería que todo lo que
necesitamos es hacer prima que es justo
lo que nos dan que prima es esta
expresión que tengo aquí ya que decir en
qué intervalo es la función que es
creciente es exactamente lo mismo que
pensar para qué intervalos g prima de x
g primas de x esto va a ser mayor que es
0 si tu razón de cambio con respecto a x
es mayor que 0 es positiva entonces tu
función original va a ser creciente
bueno pues hay varias formas de resolver
esto por ejemplo podemos trabajar con la
estructura de la derivada y pensar
cuando esto de aquí va a ser más grande
que 0 o tal vez podemos hacerlo de una
forma más metódica y para eso vamos a
fijarnos en los puntos críticos así que
déjame escribirlo aquí vamos a hablar de
los puntos críticos donde los valores
críticos para la función g
los críticos
y bueno para esto vamos a recordar que
es un punto crítico dejen los valores
críticos para que son aquellos valores
de x que hacen que ge prima de x que
prima de x esto sea igual a cero eso es
un primer caso con el otro caso es que g
prima de x prima de x sea indefinida sea
d
fin es decir vamos a buscar todas las
equis que hagan que prima de x igual a 0
kg prima de x sea indefinida y de hecho
tenemos varios vídeos sobre estos puntos
críticos y sobre valores críticos y si
te preguntas por qué esto es relevante
bueno porque justo aquí tenemos los
lugares o los posibles lugares donde el
signo de mi derivada que prima puede
cambiar donde podemos tener un cambio de
signo para ge prima entonces bueno
primero pensemos en este caso cuando que
prima de x es igual a 0 bueno la forma
de obtener que prima de x igual a 0 es
cuando el numerador en esta expresión
que tengo aquí es igual a cero y el
numerador es esta parte de arriba
entonces me quedaría que x 4 desigualdad
0 o bueno eso va a ser igual a cero
cuando
sea igual a cero así que lo voy a
escribir aquí x igual a cero hace que
prima de x igual a cero porque el
numerador se hace cero ahora bien cuando
he prima de x es indefinido bueno esta
función de aquí se hace indefinida
cuando la parte de abajo es igual a cero
es decir cuando el denominador es igual
a cero y este denominador es igual a
cero cuando x 2 es igual a 0 x menos 2
es igual a cero o dicho otra manera
x toman el valor de 2 esta es la forma
en que este denominador se haga igual a
0 y por lo tanto esta función sea
indefinida entonces tenemos dos puntos
críticos o dos valores críticos y para
ver qué es lo que pasa con la función
que te parece si dibujamos por aquí una
recta voy a dibujar una recta numérica
justo por aquí y vamos a fijarnos qué es
lo que está pasando con la función entre
estos valores críticos
que esta va a ser mi recta numérica no
ok me estoy fijando en los valores de x
y si empezamos por aquí en 0 por aquí
tengo al 0 por aquí lo voy a tomar al 1
ok por aquí me voy a tomar al 2
muy bien por acá estaré al 3
y bueno de este lado por aquí tendría al
menos 1 y ahora me voy a afiliar que es
lo que pasa entre estos puntos críticos
déjame ponerlo a este lo voy a poner con
color anaranjado es el valor de x igual
a 0
estamos justo aquí y al otro lo voy a
poner con este color con un color azul
muy bien entonces x igualados está justo
aquí y vamos a fijarnos qué es lo que
pasa entre estos puntos críticos y en
los demás intervalos es más para eso voy
a empezar con me parece con este
intervalo de aquí voy a empezar con todo
este intervalo de aquí
estoy aquí que si observas es desde
menos infinito desde menos infinito
hasta cero es un intervalo abierto y
ahora vamos a fijarnos qué es lo que
pasa con g prima en este intervalo así
que para eso vamos a fijarnos aquí en
esta función g prima de x en la función
derivada si observas aquí vamos a tener
valores negativos pero si elevamos
cualquier valor negativo al cuadrado lo
de arriba nos va a dar algo positivo nos
va a dar algo positivo sea lo que sea
elevado al cuadrado va a ser positivo
mientras no sea cero y que nos va a
quedar en el denominador bueno si
tenemos algo negativo y a esto le
restamos todavía 2 nos va a dar un
número más negativo y al elevar todo
esto al cubo observa que vamos a obtener
algo negativo un número negativo elevado
al cubo me va a dar algo negativo
entonces me quedaría la división de un
número positivo entre un número negativo
me va a dar un número negativo entonces
en este caso la derivada me quedaría
algo negativo déjenme escribirlo en este
caso g prima de x me va a dar algo
negativo y entonces lo voy a poner aquí
que prima de x en este intervalo va a
ser negativa lo que quiere decir en
definitiva que en este intervalo mi
función g va a decrecer
mi función que va a decrecer porque la
primera derivada de mi función g es
negativa muy bien ahora vamos a fijarnos
en el siguiente intervalo ahora muy bien
fijar en este intervalo que tengo aquí
en este que tengo aquí que es de cero
abierto hasta 2 muy bien qué pasa si me
tomo cualquier valor entre este
intervalo bueno pues vamos a ver cómo se
comporta la derivada de nuevo si
observas la parte de arriba va a ser
positiva va a ser positiva porque
observa que no estamos tomando unos al 0
cualquier número elevado al cuadrado es
positivo
en la parte de abajo bueno si tomamos
números entre el 0 y el 2 no sé por
ejemplo el 1 que me quedaría uno menos 2
es menos uno que es un número negativo y
es elevarlo al cubo me va a dar un
número negativo es decir cualquier
número que tengan este intervalo al
restarle 2 me va a dar algo negativo y
después al elevarlo al cubo me va a dar
otra vez algo negativo lo que quiere
decir que en este caso tengo algo
positivo entre algo negativo y eso me va
a dar un valor negativo entonces en este
caso tengo que la derivada de x va a ser
también menor que cero lo voy a escribir
aquí
prima de x en este intervalo también me
va a dar algo menor que cero y bueno por
último tenemos este intervalo de aquí
este intervalo de aquí desde el valor de
2 abierto hasta infinito vamos a ver
cómo se comporta la derivada en ese
intervalo muy bien observamos que el
numerador como ya vimos va a ser algo
positivo cualquier número el de palo
cuadrado es positivo muy bien y qué va a
pasar con la parte de abajo
bueno el denominador me va a quedar de
la siguiente manera ahora qué pasa si
tomamos valores mayores que 2 ya eso le
quitamos 2 bueno vamos a obtener un
valor positivo y si a eso no le vas al
cubo me va a dar algo positivo así que
en este caso la parte de abajo también
es positiva y me va a quedar algo
positivo entre algo positivo eso me va a
dar algo positivo lo que
es decir kg prima de x me va a dar en
este intervalo valores positivos prima
de x es mayor que 0 en este intervalo y
si ahora regresamos a la pregunta para
qué intervalos la función g es creciente
bueno va a ser en los intervalos en
donde la derivada de x sea mayor que 0 y
eso pasa justo en este intervalo de aquí
en donde x está en el intervalo abierto
de 12 infinito así que lo podemos ya
escribir aquí la respuesta sería de 2
hasta infinito bueno esta es una forma
de escribirlo porque también lo podemos
escribir común todas las x que son
mayores que 2 esa sería mi respuesta
para cualquiera de estos que tenemos
aquí
que prima de x va a ser mayor que 0 y
eso quiere decir que la función que va a
ser creciente en ese intervalo